the reality is the government is
enforcing a form of censorship on us
they're saying you can't talk about
certain subjects you're gonna sell pipes
so come and rock with me to my place is
called capital DC right in the city Adam
I Taggert has invited us down into
capital hemp we're going to descend the
steps but when we find you're gonna find
an amazing hemp store capital hemp is
the place to go for hem faced clothing
soaps paper and one of the country's
best selections of artisan glass pipes
but that all changed on october twenty
seven twenty eleven when capital hemp
was raided by police they arrested all
of our employees a customer and they
charged everybody with possession of
drug paraphernalia they went through the
tobacco shop and just took pretty much
all of the inventory over three hundred
thousand dollars worth after prosecutors
lowered their charges to avoid a jury
trial while still holding on to capital
hemp's merchandise the feds began
negotiating a deal if we agree to close
down they returned our property and that
was the best scenario because without a
jury option with a federal prosecutor
doing running the case it just didn't
seem like we would ever see our property
back to prove capital hemp was selling
paraphernalia an undercover cop visited
the store when employees corrected his
use of the word bong and changed the
subject when he brought up marijuana the
officer saw this as unnatural and
deceptive he was also suspicious of
their bookshelf what is no longer there
what's the longer here are numerous
books about drug policy basically we had
books that talked about how cannabis was
safer than alcohol we had books about
knowing your rights during police
encounters what the government was
saying is in the context of having a
tobacco shop that this would indicate in
nefarious use for the tobacco shop of
the tobacco shop is for drug
paraphernalia enough for tobacco what
are the laws regarding paraphernalia and
how could you be arrested for it really
in all 50 states sale of drug
paraphernalia is illegal under federal
law as well as in all local laws but
anything can become drug paraphernalia
that's correct we were very careful
though to sell the pipes for tobacco and
to this day we are open and operating
under those guidelines while both of
capital hemp's
and mortar locations are closing i
tinker hopes to create an online store
that will service the whole country it
didn't have to end this way capital hemp
is another victim of an ever-expanding
war on drugs that punishes controversial
free speech and small business owners
with impunity and as Washington DC moves
forward with legalizing medical
marijuana the capital hem parade sent
the harsh tone that not only
dispensaries will have to worry about
but local head shops as well